- Why is it important
to uplift other women
in all areas of life?
Like I feel like for me personally,
I feel like it's the change won't happen
unless we are daily supporting each other,
and not in competition all
the time with each other,
like obviously you're on the court,
you're in competition with people,
obviously I'm up against
awards or whatever,
but at the end of the day,
there's room for everyone,
and I feel like it's really important
for women to do that for women,
more so than men sticking up for us,
because I think that sets the example.
Do you agree?
- Yes. That's literally
what I say all the time.
Like literally I say,
there's room for all of us.
This is such a big planet,
there's room for so many of us
to have our own successful companies,
have our own TV shows,
like, to win grand slams,
there's four a year,
like there's so many opportunities,
and I just like, I don't
understand why it has to be,
it's a competition, and believe me,
when I'm out there, I
give a zillion percent.
But at the end of the
day, if someone else wins
or if someone has a successful company,
I'm genuinely happy for
them because first of all,
that affects my energy if I'm
not, and it affects who I am,
and it makes me even to be around me,
I just lose this glow,
and I don't want that.
And second of all, jealousy
is rottenness to the bone,
and I never want to do that.
And I feel like women should...
The success, I say the
success of one woman
should be the inspiration
to another, and I love that.
I love saying that because it's inspiring.
Like, oh my gosh sister you've made it.
This is great. I can do it too.
And that's what I think a lot of men do.
And I really, really, truly believe
a lot of women are leaning
into this so much more.
I can see it now, like even
when I'm in my job in tennis,
so many women are so
happy for the next person
and it's just such a
different environment,
and it's happening,
and that's what's the most exciting thing.
So I'm really excited to see that,
us being happy for each other.
Cause that's what it's about.
- Yeah. I also think it's-
- Life's too short
- Yeah, especially as mothers
of daughters and sons,
like it's really cool for us to like,
I find that that's my
biggest responsibility,
is showing her how to treat
other women in my business,
or people that I work with, or...
We're the best, we're going
to be the best example
because they're going
to follow our actions
not our words necessarily.
So I think that's the
cool thing too as a mom,
you get to show how to show
respect to other women,
instead of be envious,
instead of go for jealousy,
instead of all of that, so.
I don't know. Do you feel that as a mama?
I feel like that's my biggest thing.
I'm like, just don't fail as a mom.
I can fail as a singer, I
can fail as everything else,
but I don't want to fail as a mom.
That's my biggest thing.
- Oh that's so sweet. Yeah. No, I agree.
Cause you are lead by
example, not by words,
and actually lead by both,
but definitely by example as well.
And like, you don't want negative
energy going to your kid,
you know, that's not cool.